well everybody welcome to the Tuesday
April the 2nd 2019 session in our series
on entrepreneurship and Asian high-tech
industries for Stanford students who are
registered for credit this is 402 T and
it's available in three different
departments Electrical Engineering
East Asian Studies and East Asia
language and culture so I'm Richard
Dasher I'm the instructor for the course
and I first want to welcome everybody
today really glad that you had join us
normally I would be in the room but as
it turns out I was in Bangkok last week
and I'm stopping off in Tokyo on the way
back so we're doing our first session
very opportunistically with one of the
people who really knows the start-up
situation in Japan before I introduce
our speaker though I do want to point
out that if you're taking the course for
credit be sure you get the syllabus and
understand exactly what our requirements
are basically you're supposed to attend
in person and there are two excused
absences from that requirement if you
are registered through the Stanford
center for professional development
remotely you don't have to fulfill that
requirement but that's only for those
students there is also a requirement to
send me a weekly comment or summary of
the session that's brief 60 to 90 words
and that's due by email to me within two
weeks of the session so I look forward
to hearing from each of you or register
within the next couple of weeks there's
one excused absence from sending in a
comment so make sure you know what
that's going on today
your in-person attendance is going to be
credited by filling out the survey and
we'd also like all of our guests to fill
out the survey as well these are public
seminars we're delighted to have a mixed
audience from the Stanford community and
also from the Silicon Valley
so we're very happy that you're here
today I am delighted that our speaker is
mr. Tim Romero and I see that you see
his picture on the screen Tim is the CTO
the chief technology officer of TEPCO
ventures which is the corporate venture
capital arm of Tokyo Electric Power
Company he's probably a lot better known
as the founder and main author of the
podcast disrupting Japan and I'll let
Tim talk more about his self himself as
we get started in this presentation so
what's going to happen is that today
I'll ask Tim to give some prepared
remarks then we'll go into a Q&A session
and hope that you will ask some
questions office I'll talk more about
that when we get to the Q&A fantastic ok
for jurors thank you ok today
I'd rather rather than give you a lot of
numbers and statistics what I thought I
would do is give you a rundown of what I
see is the most important aspects about
the Japanese startup ecosystem how
innovation happens in Japan and the
unique parts of it and where we think
we're gonna go from here and we'll get
some Q&A afterwards we're gonna cover a
lot of ground so hopefully we can have a
lively discussion afterwards so at first
I am going to give you some some
headline numbers to give you a sense of
what venture capital is doing in Japan
now we'll talk about venture capital I
will give you some numbers but when I
give you numbers they are to frame a
larger point and it's the larger point I
want to communicate we're gonna talk a
bit about how startups and enterprise
work together because that is far more
importance in Japan
it is in the US startups are evolving
quite differently here and the way that
the innovation is filtering into larger
and into larger industry and to society
as a whole the mechanisms of difference
in Japan than they are in the West and
that's pretty interesting then we'll
cover some recent changes in the startup
ecosystem how things have changed in the
last five years in the last ten years in
particular and wrap up talking about
where we go from here some some trends
that we see in the ground on the ground
here that no one else is talking about
and let's get started but before we do I
suppose I should tell you a little bit
about myself and let you know why you
should listen to me at least for the
next 30 40 minutes or so so briefly very
briefly I've started for startups in
Japan over the last 25 years that I've
been here I've sold to I've bankrupted -
so 5050 it's not bad as far as startups
go I'm currently the CTO of TEPCO
ventures I teach corporate innovation
and entrepreneurship at New York
University's Shinagawa campus here I
work with several large Japanese
companies on their startup outreach
programs but as Richard mentioned I'm
probably best known for a podcast I run
called disrupting Japan and it's
something I started as a hobby five
years ago and it just got out of control
and is through much larger than I ever
expected a hood we've got basically I
sit down twice a month with Japanese
startup founders and I talk with them
not so much about their specific company
but about what it's like to be an
innovator and a culture that prizes
conformity what it's like to try sell to
large corporations as a tiny startup
sometimes things like how they managed
to convince their wife to let them quit
Mitsubishi and start this crazy little
side project
that comes up more than you think and
it's it's all in English so alcohol is
involved in more than a few of these
interviews and the amazing thing though
is when you talk with startup founders
when you talk with people who are out
there building their own companies and
making sales every day you get a really
really different perspective on the
future of the Japanese economy and the
state of innovation and change then you
do and speak with politicians and
academics and there's a really good
reason for that but that's getting a
little away from our discussion today so
look at jump in a second before you go
on to it cause I want to say that I
cannot emphasize enough how great these
interviews are on disrupting Japan and
one of the things that that's done Tim
is one of the key people in the Advisory
Council that runs the japan-us
Innovation Awards each year and we look
at probably 60 or 70 startup companies
in Japan to select five companies to
bring to Silicon Valley
every summer and I think Kim knows at
least half of them every year so and has
interviewed most of these most of the
CEOs of the ones that that wind up
making it into our program so I do want
to say that how Duke is disrupting Japan
yes right okay so what I'll let you go
on and now talk about the ecosystem
Thanks and you check it out if you're
interested in innovation in Japan but
let's talk venture capital because that
seems to be where most discussions about
innovation in Japan start and sadly
where most of them tend to end as well
but it is important so this shows a
total venture capital investment in
Japan and in 20 2015 the total value of
investment exceeded its previous peak
that had hit in 2006 and has been
climbing steadily
ever since now it's interesting I've
never heard a completely satisfying
explanation for this interesting trend
you see happening in 2016-17 where
despite the number of so Tim was talking
about the number of deals reducing in
Japan and the amount of money going into
the deals increasing between 2016 and
2017 yep why yeah I think that well
actually before I before I give you my
own theory of why we're seeing this
happening and why we think it's going to
continue I don't have the 2018 numbers
yet they tend to run about a quarter
behind which means like any minute now
we should get them but these trends seem
to be pretty solid and persistent and
before I give you my theory of why we
see this happening I want to talk a
little bit about how this money where
this money is coming from so the vast
majority of it is coming from Japanese
VC and corporate venture capital and
we'll talk more about that in some
detail later but it fundamentally works
the same way it does in the West
crowdfunding provides an unfortunately
small amount of capital in Japan
compared to the u.s. crowdfunding in
Japan there there are a few popular
crowdfunding sites but crowdfunding has
never been able to shake its image as
kind of a social good as like an NPO
which is how they started in Japan
another change and this is important
another source of funding is angel
investing which until about 10 years ago
angel investing in Japan had been
lawyers and doctors and other wealthy
individuals with money but no particular
startup expertise investing in startups
right now is really the very first time
we're seeing entrepreneurs who have
exited their startups who have been
successful investing in the next
generation of startups and mentoring
them and Silicon Valley rather than the
venture capital making it successful I
think the real key
has been that eight or nine generations
of successful entrepreneurs mentoring
the next generation and we're just
seeing that starting in Japan and I
think that's one of the most exciting
things and most important things going
on here right now now back to why we see
this trend going there's a bit of a
barbell problem with investing so once a
startup gets to a growth stage where
they've proven their mark their product
market fit they are generating revenues
they defined improving their business
model then you've got a model that you
can pass off to any halfway intelligent
MBA they can put it in spreadsheets they
can apply a dozen different valuation
metrics to it and come out with a value
now once the companies in that stage
there's almost unlimited investment
available to that company because it's
it's a known model on the other side the
seed stage there's almost unlimited
investment there as well because that
strategy for investment is you've you do
a little bit of due diligence you have
someone check that the product is
plausible they have a couple of users
they've got some initial traction and
that the team seems solid and then you
write lots and lots and lots of $50,000
$100,000 checks it's also a relatively
easy model the trouble is that between
these two ends you've got let's call
them five million dollar checks well
this is too big for people just to write
lots and lots of them if you decide to
invest my five million dollars and that
deal goes bad you're gonna have to
explain why and so the fact is you know
it's still too early to have traction
it's still too early to pull out the
spreadsheets so that part of venture
capital between that seed and growth is
difficult it requires people with
genuine skill and that's why we are
seeing the
these trends and we're actually seeing
similar trends globally as well so it's
just more money's pouring into growth
and the rest of the pipeline isn't
keeping up but there's something else
here that these numbers don't really
tell and I think is more important in
the long run and that is that there's
something fundamentally different now
than there was during the dot-com era
and that is there is actually a startup
ecosystem by which I mean one thing that
didn't really happen before was that we
had in the dot-com era usually the
startups of which mine was one we were
looking for large corporate partners
almost like a a sponsor and that was
that was fine but now there's enough
startups where they're actually doing
business with each other where a large
part of the startup revenues are coming
from other startups and this lets
innovation propagate much much faster
than having to convince a large
corporation simply because startups will
take more risks they'll move faster and
it allows startups to sell innovative
business solutions much quicker this is
total investment from the US in Japan
now even if we adjust for the size the
population or the the size of the
economy the u.s. invests about 10 to 15
times as much as Japan does and actually
it's a little worse than this because
the way Japan defines venture capital
investment is looser than the way it's
defined in the US now what's just mean
does it mean that Japan needs more
investment well if you talk to he sees
they'll always tell you that there's way
too much money in the market and that
the the startup prices are far too high
but they'll always tell you that I have
never talked to a VC at any time in the
last 25 years where they were not
complaining
startups were overpriced now founders
will always tell the opposite of course
now my own sense is that there's about
as much money available in Japan as can
be sensibly deployed in fact if anything
there's maybe a little bit more money
available that can be sensibly deployed
in Japan so the investment gap is is
huge but what does that mean
why is that important the goal is not to
copy what's worked in the United States
if Japan doubled the amount of venture
capital available there'd be nowhere to
put it but there's clearly room for
growth and in Japan now we've got over
15 startups that have raised more than
50 million dollars and we have two
unicorns
well technically one unicorn since Marik
re IPO now frankly I don't really like
unicorn counting as a method of
measuring innovation I I think I mean
10 right now there are 280 unicorns in
the world 10 years ago there were zero
does that mean we're 280 times more
innovative no of course not
you know China has far more unicorns in
the United States that doesn't mean
China's more innovative there are kind
of macroeconomic trends that are more
responsible for the existence of
unicorns then the the innovation but
that said any ecosystem is gonna have to
develop businesses at scale if
innovation is meaningful it has to have
a real impact long-term whether that is
through IPL or whether that is through
b2b sales or consumer sales let's talk a
bit about start-up and enterprise
collaboration because in Japan this is a
major way that innovation does get
propagated into society as a whole now
there are
the four primary means of collaboration
that I when I'm working with my
corporate clients these are the four
ways I generally steer them in terms of
interacting with startups and we'll talk
briefly about each of them but you know
corporate venture capital where the
companies actually invest in startups
acquisitions where they purchase them
accelerators and open innovation
programs where they work directly with
startups to try to foster either an
acquisition at the end or a joint
marketing or collaboration projects and
co-development projects where a large
enterprise will outsource a key
component of its technology or as
product to startups which is more common
in Japan than you might imagine
certainly more kata you don't more
common in Japan than in the u.s. now
there also there's actually nine means
of collaboration but the five on the
right side or I guess the left side
decide on the five side don't really
work well in Japan and the reason for
that is a much longer discussion and we
can dive into it in Q&A if you're
interested but the four on the the four
side are the ones that that really
worked now before I dive into late these
mechanisms of innovation sharing of how
startups and enterprise work together I
think it's important to explain how much
things have changed in Japan over the
last 10 years or certainly over the last
20 particularly in the attitude of the
way large enterprises views startups so
I started my first company in Japan in
1998 and at that point if I wanted to
work with a large company if I wanted to
work with Mitsubishi or Toyota I would
be pushed down through like three levels
of subcontractors before there would be
any chance to work with them at all so
innovation just almost by definition
could not move up that that supply chain
now this is totally changed today almost
every major corporation has
at least one team that is focused on
reaching out to startups and trying to
find innovation now what's what's
changed there's a lot of government
programs there's a lot of educational
programs but to be honest I think the
single biggest effect in in changing the
way that Japanese companies think about
startups and innovation has been the
Government of Japan the Prime Minister
of Japan himself Prime Minister obey has
gone on stage several times and said
startup to the future of Japan
we need this innovation vitalized Japan
and the first time he did that probably
the next day the CEO of every major
company in Japan was saying what is this
startup stuff and why aren't we doing it
and there's lots of all the programs and
things that are run I think are good but
I think that the Government of Japan is
very good at just shining the spotlight
on startups and saying this is worth
paying it after that the collaboration
started there was a few successful case
studies and it's been gathering steam
ever since the other thing I think has
happened is the the government of japan
has said clearly and that they're not
back stopping big companies anymore
when sharp was allowed to be purchased
by a foreign company i think that sent
some shockwaves through corporate japan
a lot of people are just assuming that
the japanese government would always
bail out the large companies they would
find someone to merge them with they
would make sure those jobs were
protected and that didn't happen and so
a lot of unprofitable companies now are
that the CEOs are have to figure out how
to make profit how to turn their company
around and really lit a fire under their
ass and this is good for Japanese
startups it's good for Japanese
innovation
it is also really wonderful for foreign
companies who are trying to enter the
Japanese market because that same
attitude that same welcomed these two
innovation works whether the innovation
is coming from the inside Japan or
outside Japan all right let's take each
one of these these mechanisms
individually and quickly so at first
corporate venture capital this is I
think most of the class knows how this
works it is just large companies
investing in startups with the hope that
they will learn a bit about the startups
and perhaps collaborate with in practice
this is about the least effective way
for large companies to interact with
startups both in Japan and globally but
particularly in Japan because way
corporate venture capital is run they
tend to hire people with a background
and banking and venture capital but
don't don't really understand the
business that they're running and more
importantly don't have the political
clout within the large organizations to
get different divisions to work with
these startups so some venture capital
funds are profitable but but very few
have had the intended effect of letting
these startup innovations filter into
the larger organization acquisitions
this is something that's new in Japan I
mean not acquisitions themselves but
until very recently M&A has always been
distressed assets in Japan large
companies would acquire another company
when they could pick up assets or
customers at fire sale prices or when
the government kind of forced a a merger
upon them strategic M&A is a relatively
new concept we've seen a handful of
acquisitions most of the acquisitions
that happen in Japan are 10 million to
30 million dollar range
which is still you know it's not it's
not Silicon Valley IPO money but is
still incredibly motivating to a
potential founder to be able to work on
something really hard for seven years
and walk away with eight million dollars
and that's one of the reasons we're
seeing so much new startups happening
now I don't think now the my clients and
people I talk to everyone is talking a
good game about MA everyone understand
URI that strategic M&A is a way to
further their business and a lower risk
way of rolling out new products and what
there's been very very little motion on
that it's just starting to take off now
and I don't ever think that we'll see
strategic M&A in Japan the way we do in
the US which is I mean you the American
corporations do this better than anyone
in the world so they will be able to say
okay we want to enter market X who are
the top three private companies in the
space six months from now we're gonna
buy one of them I don't think that'll
ever happen in Japan I think we're gonna
see more long-term collaborations but
again the most important thing is that
the acquisition strategic acquisitions
are happening and that's providing a
real incentive for people to start
Congress now actually one thing I do
want to talk about with the acquisitions
this is one part where venture capital
in Japan is different in the u.s.
without getting into too deeply Japanese
venture capital the entire industry is
set up to have lots of low value low
risk IPOs so is in the US you might have
a VC firm that understands that nine out
of a nine out of ten investments are
going to be worthless
and 10% to in required really high
return Japan is traditionally work the
other way where they understand 10% our
investments are going to go bankrupt and
90% of them will provide a nice to
x-3x return at IPO this is starting to
change because the large traditional
Japanese VCS are losing deal flow
foreign money and foreign strategy is
coming to Japan and they're out bidding
the traditional VCS on the most
promising new technology companies so
we're seeing a slow change to that but
as a result a lot of traditional VC
still try to push their portfolio
companies to IPO early and safely but
some of the more powerful startup
founders in Japan and I've talked to the
number of more on the show have fought
with their investors and just said no
we're going to stay private longer if
you want to be part of the next round
that's great if you don't that's okay
too
so it's it's changing and probably the
most well-known acquisition was last
year or two years ago now was a ke TDI's
200 million dollar acquisition sort and
that sort of will everyone up corporate
accelerators they're a little bit
different in Japan than they are in the
United States
what job what is called a corporate
accelerator in Japan tends to be called
an open innovation program in the US
again I think this goes back to the
different approach to acquisitions there
are a number of companies a number of
very promising Japanese startups who
entire their entire marketing strategy
depends on working with and trusting
large Japanese companies long term so
these might be innovative imaging
companies like El pixel who is using
actually yeah epics who's using AI and
imaging of MRI scans to detect potential
diseases their entire marketing strategy
is to partner with device manufacturers
they're not reaching out to doctors and
and this is really common in Japan
whereas in the u.s. I mean even as an
American that strikes me as incredibly
dangerous I would I don't think I could
allow that to happen I want to have the
direct relationship with the end-user
what it's working in Japan these
long-term both ways trust relationships
do seem to be stable and productive and
I think they might end up in mas in five
years or ten years and why that is is
another deep dive that we won't get into
today the last is a co development
projects this is actually similar to
open innovation and continues on the
same point I was talking about that the
there is this relationship of trust
between enterprise and startups acquire
and vendor that can last for many many
years and many many budgeting cycles and
it's allowing the the ecosystem to
develop differently here in the news in
the press but all is not well so I've
worked with both startups and
enterprises in every single one of these
models and it can and and sometimes it
is incredibly productive but I'd say the
the biggest problems that play these
collaborations is in communication and
expectation there's kind of an impedance
mismatch between startups and Enterprise
models and it's just things like on the
enterprise side I've got to I don't know
how many times I've had this
conversation which is basically okay now
when the startups talk about testing and
QA they need something completely
different than when you talk about
testing and QA they're not lying to you
but that's really what Q & A is in the
startup world and on the flip side I
spend a lot of time working with
startups saying like no no and he said
he'll get back to you with an answer in
two weeks
he's not blowing you off he's not trying
to get rid of you it really probably
takes him a week to get an appointment
with his own boss so most of the things
that most of the times when things fall
apart it falls apart for those kind of
communication reasons or when the large
enterprise doesn't really know what it
wants a lot of times these programs are
developed by committee and it's the goal
is basically to go out and get some of
that innovation and bring it back oK
we've spent a lot of time on this
particular topic and I think it's time
well spent because I think the major
mechanism for innovation Japan is going
to be through this startup enterprise
collaboration that won't exist nearly as
much in the US so let's talk about
starts but before I do so everyone loves
to talk about startups and trends and
how things are changing and how this
uniquely affects Japanese culture but
before we go into the culture argument I
want to explain my view on culture now
what would I say culture is I
don't mean things like food and language
and history obviously that's real the
the culture I'm talking about
is when we use culture as an excuse to
explain anything that we cannot
understand so well why why aren't there
as many startups in Japan well that's
just a risk-averse culture or why is
this decision making so hard well that's
just the corporate culture no I think
it's far more productive to view things
in terms of risks and rewards in terms
of the kind of game theory so if you
want to know why there are so many more
startups in Japan today than there were
30 years ago
don't look for stories about culture
look at the risks and rewards
so let's let's teleport back 30 years
and we have a promising new graduate
from Tokyo University now he has the
option of going to work for a big
company or starting his own company if
he goes to work for a big company he's
guaranteed lifetime employment if he
does a good job he'll have steady large
promotions for the next 30 years and
does a bad job he'll have steady small
promotions for the next 30 years it's a
high respected position if he starts his
own company well at that point there
were very little M&A so his only hope is
to IPO that firm and if he does I appeal
the firm his financial rewards and his
social status is about the same as a
senior executive at a Mitsubishi or a
large bank but if it doesn't work well
he doesn't get a second chance he can't
get hired into another company and the
bankruptcy law is particularly at that
time then he'd be carrying those debts
around for his entire life so going into
a big company was all reward and no risk
starting your own company was huge and
risky with very little reward
so everyone made the perfectly rational
decision to go work for big companies
well fast-forward to today and let's
look at that equation to get lifetime
employments unless you're working for
the government no longer exists you're
no longer guaranteed a steady stream of
promotions you very well be in your you
know you're in late 40s and the company
could fire you or you could get sold to
a foreign company and have them fired
but on the other hand starting a start
of your own company you no longer have
to take out loans there's plenty of risk
capital available you're not staking
your whole life when one decision
furthermore it's certainly into your
early 30s there's a lot more job
mobility you can get it you can get a
new job if you school
and more importantly the risk we're
seeing M&A we're seeking the ability to
really work hard for five years six
years and walk away with six seven
million dollars if all goes right so now
joining a big companies become less
rewarding and more risky and starting
your own companies become less risky and
more rewarding so people are making the
perfectly rational decision to start
more startups now you can call that
culture if you like but the way I look
at it I mean if you want to change the
culture change the risks and rewards and
people adjust their behavior so with all
that kind of out of the way and and I I
find looking at risks and rewards to be
a lot more demystifying than trying to
come up with cultural stories but let's
let's look at some of the most important
trends and I'm gonna go through this
kind of quickly because I realize we're
running out of time so first I think is
a change of the general social attitude
towards startups and innovation one of
one of the biggest influencers here i've
mentioned has been Prime Minister Ave
and the obby government in general just
saying the things about startups another
strangely was the movie was social
networking that was really what put
startups into Japanese social
consciousness and and to give you an
idea how bad it was at my first company
there was a new grad from I think he's
Hamas it up that I really wanted to hire
and he wanted to join my company but his
mom was saying no we're not gonna let
him do that and so I had to go meet mom
it was hard to hire back that let me
tell you and so I explained to her what
my company did and she didn't understand
this whole startup thing she was like so
wait you're so you're getting this money
from these people and then you're gonna
sell it to these other people for like
20 times more in a few years it sounded
like a scam to her and he did end up
joining the company I had to meet mom
twice I don't have to do that anymore
everyone understands how startups
working and it's generally viewed as a
good thing we're seeing specific cities
that are startup that I consider startup
hotspots in Japan now Tokyo is by far
the biggest but I think two of the most
creative and interesting places in Japan
are Olga and more recently killed and I
think it's important
Silicon Valley did not come into
existence in New York or Chicago or DC
and I really believed you need a certain
distance away from political and
financial power to really innovate and
to really create something that is and
so if you want to look at something
that's really interesting in Japan and
and that are developing their own ways
those are two cities to look at another
thing is a high quality
anger sourcing so as as Richard
mentioned earlier with the Japan Society
Awards we've been doing this for eight
years now
nine years until last year there was
always this gap between the Japanese the
quality of the Japanese startups and the
quality of the San Francisco startups
and it was something that at least on
the Japan side we were always a little
over self-conscious about but I think
last year was really the first time at
least the first month at i sat there
realizing like no these are for their
age and they're rich you know how long
they've been in business I put these
Japanese firms I'd stack them up against
the the best of anywhere in the world
so the Japanese founders have learned
incredibly fast and another thing that's
interesting is the number of women
entrepreneurs in Japan I think as a
percentage there are more female
founders in Japan than there are in the
United States and I haven't actually
counted but I think about one-fifth of
my guests on disrupting Japan are women
and there's a lot of reasons for this
rather than going into in-depth I want
to tell you what two different female
founders have told me as what they
believe the reason for this is and
they've said that it is actually easier
in Japan to start a company to start a
startup as a woman because if you go to
a really good school and you're a man
that comes with some really heavy social
expectations your your parents and all
the rest of your family
their status depends on how well you do
and what company you go into and
everybody's watching but if you're a
girl well then your parents are much
more like you say oh yeah that startup
think that sounds fun you know go do
that for a few years and yeah I think
it's there is something to that but we
are seeing a lot of really high quality
women founders so my last thought I want
to leave you with is butterfills so why
butterflies the Japanese both the jet
let's call it Japanese power structure
whether it's industry or senior
academics or people in government they
are looking to startups as a way to
generate innovation generate economic
activity and they're doing that but what
they really want is to generate economy
and economic activity without changing
anything and that's not gonna happen
that can't so why butterflies if you
release butterflies into a forest where
there's never been any butterflies
before you don't have
forest plus butter gloss there's
something different those butterflies
are going to eat some plants that
weren't being eaten before there's gonna
be other things that are gonna be able
to eat them and thrive that couldn't
before the ecosystem as a whole is going
to be thrown out of balance for a little
bit and it's going to evolve into
something stronger and something
different and something different in a
very unpredictable way and I think
that's where we are in Japan right now
so I'd like to open it up for Q&A and
but and thanks for inviting me I really
enjoy it please check out the podcast
and follow me on social media if you
like so thanks very much for coming
today and please join me in thanking Tim
for a great presentation
[Applause]